Transcriber: Ghada Khalil
المدقّق: Yahya Mansour
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم.
معكم قيس الخُنجي،
وأنا سعيد لمشاركتي في TEDx هذا العام.
اليوم سوف أتحدث عن مشواري
في ريادة الأعمال.
لكن قبل أن أبدأ في سرد رحلتي
في ريادة الأعمال،
سوف أتكلم عن كيف بدأت
أو ما هي المُحفزات التي جعلتني أبدأ.
كنتُ أعمل في القطاع المصرفي
قرابة 4 إلى 5 أعوام،
وأهلتني هذه الوظيفة من حيث الخبرة،
فقد اكتسبتُ خبرة كبيرة؛
لأن أي شركة في بدايتها
ستتعامل بالطبع مع القطاع المصرفي،
سواء البنوك أو الجهات التمويلية الأخرى.
قرَرتُ في عام 2010 أن أُنشئ شركتي الخاصة.
ومن المُحفزات الأخرى لي أيضًا
هي كوني من عائلة تجارية في السلطنة،
كما أنني كُنت وما زلتُ عضوًا
في منظمة رواد الأعمال في فرع السلطنة،
وهي تضم قرابة 17000عضوًا
من جميع أنحاء العالم، 50 منهم في السلطنة.
قد شجعتني كل هذه المُحفزات
على البدء في تجارتي الخاصة.
وأطلقتُ شركة “قيس المتحدة للتجارة”
في عام 2010،
واستمرت الشركة قرابة الثلاث سنوات.
كانت فكرتها بسيطة للغاية.
كُنت أفكر في جلب مُنتجات
غير متوفرة في السوق،
لكن هذا لم يكُن كافيًا بالطبع؛
فدراسة السوق
وإعداد الخطط التسويقية أيضًا
هي أمور لم أُطبقها بالشكل الصحيح،
ولذلك لم تصمد الشركة لأكثر من عامين
أو عامين ونصف تقريبًا.
لم أُجرِ دراسة جدوى، وهذه هي إحدى الأشياء
التي تعلمتها من هذه التجربة أيضًا،
وكذلك لم يُكن للمنتج علامة تجارية.
وهذا هو أحد أسباب تأثُّر قطاع المنتجات
كنتيجة لعدم وجود اسم مُميز
وهوية خاصة بها في السوق.
حتى لو كان الاسم قويًا،
ستحتاج إلى إدارة تسويقية قوية أيضًا.
قَررتُ أن أُنشئ شركة أخرى
وأسستُ شركة مُختصة بعدة أنشطة:
كان النشاط الأول
هو التعاقد مع الجامعات والمستشفيات،
وكُنا نرسل المرضى والطلبة
إلى جامعات ومستشفيات معينة بالتعاقد معها،
ونأخذ نسبتنا من هذه الجامعات والمستشفيات.
لكن التسويق حينها لم يكُن قويًا كذلك؛
لأن أدوات التسويق لم تكُن متوفرة
قبل انتشار منصات التواصُل الاجتماعي
وما يُماثلها من أدوات التسويق الأخرى.
واستمر النشاط في هذه الشركة
قرابة العام ونصف.
حاولنا أن نتوسع في أنشطة أخرى
كالاستثمار في الطاقة البديلة
سواء الطاقة الشمسية أو غيرها،
وتعاقدنا مع شركة إسبانية
لقراءة العدادات الرقمية وتطبيق مفهوم:
“سمارت سيتي” أو “سمارت ريدرز“.
واتخاذ هذه الخطوة
كان لا بُد أن يسبقه توجُّه حكومي بالطبع،
أي أنه يجب أن تكون الحكومة
تنوي تطبيق ذلك ضمن خططها.
في ذلك الوقت، قبل 10 أعوام أو أقل قليلًا
لم يُكن هذا التوجُّه الحكومي موجودًا
بسبب وجود عوامل اجتماعية
كان من المُمكن أن تضر بهذا القطاع؛
فقراءة العدادات في الوقت الحالي
مهمة يقوم بها البشر،
وفي حالة استبدالها بالقراءة رقمية،
سوف يفقد بعض الأشخاص وظائفهم.
وبالتالي لم يكُن التوقيت مناسبًا.
كانت الفكرة جيدة،
لكن من الأفضل أن تُطبّق مُستقبلًا؛
لأنها لم تكُن مناسبة في ذلك التوقيت.
كانت هذه شركتي الثانية،
أما الشركة الثالثة
فقد أنشأتها قبل 8 أعوام تقريبًا،
وبعتها قبل عام ونصف بعد أن تلقيتُ
عرضًا جيدًا لشرائها، ولله الحمد.
كانت الشركة عبارة عن معمل
كُنا نُصنع فيه أجهزة،
وكان اسم الشركة هو “جينيسيز إنترناشونال“.
كُنا نُصنع أجهزة لفحص عينات البترول،
وكانت شركة فريدة من نوعها في المنطقة،
لذلك كنتُ أكتسب خبرات
في هذا المجال من الدول المُجاورة
كالهند وإيران ودول أخرى.
استمرينا قرابة 8 أعوام
وكُنا نبيع أجهزتنا في السلطنة
وخارجها، ولله الحمد.
وهناك شركة ألمانية مُختصة بذلك،
ومقرها الإقليمي في دبي،
تواصلت معنا قبل عام ونصف، ولله الحمد،
وقدمت لنا عرضًا لشرائها.
وبعد نقاش وجدال طويل اتفقنا على سعر مُعين
وتمت البيعة، ولله الحمد.
ثم ظهرت الجائحة،
وأحمد الله أنني بعت الشركة
في التوقيت الصحيح؛
لأنه إن لم أكُن قد بعتها،
فالله أعلم بما كان يُمكن أن يحدُث.
فالحمد لله على كل حال.
وحاليًا لدى  أكثر من اقتراح
لكي أبدأ شيئًا جديدًا،
لكن التوقيت غير مُناسب بسبب الجائحة.
لكن الأفكار لا تتوقف؛
فلدي مجموعة أفكار
وسوف أبدأ في شيء جديد بإذن الله،
لكن لا بُد من اختيار التوقيت المُناسب
وكذلك المكان المُناسب
ولا بُد من تحديد الهدف؛
فإن لم نبدأ اليوم متى سنبدأ إذن؟
لا بُد أن تكون مُستعدًا.
ونصيحتي للشباب هي التركيز
ويجب أن تكون الفكرة جيدة،
ويجب أن يكون توقيتها مناسبًا وكذلك موقعها.
ويجب أن تختار أشخاصًا ذوي كفاءة عالية
وأن تتحلى بكثير من الصبر،
وأن تُجري دراسة جدوى محترفة،
وأن تكون لديك خارطة طريق
تساعدك على تنفيذ الدراسة.
وعليك الاهتمام بالأرقام،
فأنا شخصيًا أحب أن أطلع على الأرقام دائمًا
لأنها هي التي تساعدني على اتخاذ القرار.
هذا هو مشواري في ريادة الأعمال بشكل مختصر،
وهذه هي رسالتي للشباب،
وهي أنه لا بُد أن تبدأ من اليوم،
فلو لم تبدأ اليوم، متى ستبدأ؟
بالطبع يجب توخي الحذر
عند التعامل مع بعض الأمور،
لكن دراسة الجدوى كفيلة بمساعدتنا
على تقليل عوامل الخطأ أو الفشل في المشروع.
أنا لا أحب كلمة الفشل
وأستبدلها دائمًا بكلمة التعثُّر
لأنها أقل وطأةً على المُستمع أو المُشاهد.
والتعثُّر وارد الحدوث،
لكن ما هو إلا محطة ستتعلم منها الكثير،
لتبني وتطور من نفسك لأجل المُستقبل
وسيكون المستقبل مشرقًا إن شاء الله.
وأود أن أذكر أيضًا
أنني كنت عضو مجلس إدارة في عدة شركات،
منها: “الشركة العمانية للهندسة والاستثمار”
و“شركة الأسماك العُمانية”
و“شركة مسقط للتأمين“،
و“صندوق تنمية مشاريع الشباب” (شراكة)
ومازلتُ عضوًا فيه إلى يومنا هذا.
و“شراكة” هي أحد الصناديق التمويلية
الموجودة في السلطنة أيضًا.
هذه هي رسالتي بكل اختصار.
أتمنى التوفيق للجميع،
وألقاكُم بخير إن شاء الله.